talk about the ultimate never judge a
book by it's cover movie Kung Fu Panda I
think is the dumbest sounding title I've
ever heard and it looked like the film
was gonna represent that stupid sounding
title to Jack Black as a panda get raid
ask for the refund but watching this
film not only was I shocked at how funny
and likeable the characters are but good
god it's beautiful I couldn't believe
how much atmosphere movement color and
even serve classic philosophies that
this movie adapted I think it's actually
sort of right up there with Shrek 2 is
one of the great animated comedies ok so
Jack Black is a panda named PO he's a
big fan of the fearsome five a group of
martial artists who were actually all
named after martial arts moves like the
snake the crane the monkey and so forth
at one point the great master is about
to choose who's gonna be the Dragon
Warrior the martial artist who's going
to lead the way and save the day Oh
accidentally gets flung into the mix and
the master selects him everyone
including Po himself thinks that the
master has made a mistake but the master
believes that the chips fall where they
may and decides to go ahead with his
decision pose teacher played by Dustin
Hoffman tries everything he can to train
him so hard that he'd have no choice but
to go away but Howe is so excited and so
full of determination that it never even
comes into his mind but when an ancient
evil breaks out of prison and vows to
destroy them all the race is on to see
if they can get PO to be the real Dragon
Warrior before the villain around the
world they create is a very unique and
pretty world to look at it lives sort of
in that same timeline as Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon or other martial arts
movies but it has a modern-day sense of
humor as a good modern-day sense of
humor Paul was very likable in his
innocence and his need not to give up
and the other characters are very
relatable and how they think they've
been gypped let's slowly start to open
up to his charm while it is essentially
a comedy it does surprisingly well
mixing in drama and the emotions that
anyone would feel being put in these
circumstances teachings and the
philosophies actually do sort of stick
to a martial arts set of ideals I mean
okay it's either a little play down or
exaggerated but they're still there and
on top of that the martial arts in this
movie is pretty good too the
totally takes advantage of the fact that
it's animated and it's a comedy and it
gives us some unbelievably fast
stylish action-packed fight sequences
these are great fun to watch if I did
have one problem with the movie is that
the villain does seem kind of weak
I mean he's not terrible the voice actor
isn't terrible even the design isn't
that bad they even gave him a decent
backstory but I think compared to
everything else and just how much he's
been built up you could have had someone
either more evil or more funny in this
part we try to play it half in half but
I think they should lean more towards
one or the other but honestly that's a
nitpick he still serves as a threat he's
still really cool at what he does and he
even gets a funny line here and there
overall I think Kung Fu Panda is
wonderful and just saying that sentence
sounds so strange to me Kung Fu Panda is
wonderful but you know what if there's
anything the movie wants to teach it's
never judged solely by appearances and
maybe it teaches that less a little
better than I thought even to a point
where the film looks so ridiculous and
over-the-top that it actually sort of
works strike that it doesn't sort of
work it really works Kung Fu Panda is a
great film for children and adults of
any age it's energized it's fun it's
smart its humorous it has great
characters it has a wonderful story see
it if you haven't already
you